happy lundi Gras have the little little
ring they gave me last night it's the
Monday before Ash Wednesday I just got
back from my first Mardi Gras in New
Orleans it was unbelievable okay I
attended the crew of Bacchus their
parade 50th anniversary rendezvous
watching more than 30 floats and
marching bands come into the Convention
Center in New Orleans
yesterday was unbelievable late last
night it's one of those surreal
experiences you really have to see to
believe but Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo found another crew dedicated to
honoring our veterans and transforming
their lives watch in New Orleans
along the Mississippi a pre parade party
is underway these are members of a Mardi
Gras crew known as the Legion of Mars
Mardi Gras cruise hosts Bowles parades
and undertake philanthropic works
throughout the year but this particular
career was founded by a group of jag
lawyers from New Orleans Rico
Alvin dia was one of them a few of us
had returned from active duty serving
overseas and we noticed that there was
there was no cruise around that would
actually honor just a military and with
so many people serving overseas we
wanted a crew in Mardi Gras we wouldn't
have fun but we wanted to do something
that would honored the military of
fallen soldiers wounded warriors so many
out there of the 70 plus cruise of Mardi
Gras the organizations that actually
parade and roll through these streets
this is the only one
Legion of Mars dedicated to celebrating
and populated by veterans and as you see
rain or shine
they're rolling a little rain could not
stop this crew many of the riders have
seen combat in Iraq Afghanistan and
Vietnam some of these vets this is not
just a parade but an experience of joy
and healing fred Burmaster and bill trow
served in vietnam together but it was
the Legion of Mars that reunited them
after more than 45 years and changed
them for the better I guess everybody
knows the story about Vietnam veteran
how we were treated and all of this
other stuff and so you know in PTSD so I
really wasn't a joint and so my wife
thought that it would be a good idea for
me personally to join a group that was
you know catering to vets and it has
it's been a blessing it's kind of
brought me out of my shell and you know
gave me an opportunity to meet folks and
you know I feel a lot comfortable being
around veterans and caters to veterans
and an active military so we not only
get you to interact with people who had
served years ago like us but we also get
to interact with it with the new people
and people that are serving our country
today
are we here every branch of the military
is honored and before the parade special
mention is made of the Purple Heart
recipients when the crew invites to ride
with them each year and this float they
really went out of their way to do this
for us and we really appreciate it
because so many people forgot the
Vietnam veteran I'm born and raised in
New Orleans been in many careers but
never ridden this is the first time I've
ever ridden in a bridge
[Applause]
it's amazing how much support we get
from the general public people really
appreciate the military and that's why
it's so important for our members to see
that a lot of the guys that might not
experience that when they came back
they're seeing that on the streets of
New Orleans it's just fantastic of all
the crews of Mardi Gras all the Legion
of Mars has a reciprocity that makes it
unique while they toss beads and their
hallmark camp teams to the crowd
disprove get something back from parade
doors the respect and gratitude they so
richly deserve Raymond Arroyo Fox News
reporting from New Orleans
[Music]